dans un bon soir bonsoir merci d'être là
on va commencer tout de suite vous savez
comment on fait non non vous allez
apprendre en dessous non à ça commence
fort ce qu'ils y ont
montré lui
oui ouais ouais tout le monde l'a fait
mettre jean marie messier un jeu dire
moi je le fais c'est pour une raison non
bon c'est vrai qu'avec vous s'est pas un
argument qui peut vraiment faire de ces
cinq faut pas jouer la finale qui peut
cependant pas dans ta gueule
et là je suis très calme ouais pour
l'instant mais tu dors les questions non
c'est ce qui annonce la promotion qui
vous amène en plus c'est pour sa réserve
lors des fous on est prêt
même monseigneur di falco l'a fait je
sais pas quels arguments je peux vous
donner en fait d'un lavilliers falco
surtout postule non alors qu' alors à
balladur
bien alors donc lors des fous aux
éditions soleil c'est un album je montre
alors y'a un cd d'abord et ce cd
comporte treize chansons de bernard
lavilliers à 14 parlant dans treize
chansons de berlin rien parce que et
puis ensuite il ya des dessinateurs de
bandes dessinées qui ont fait treize
histoires par rapport aux chansons de
bernard lavilliers sûr que c'est pas 14
mars et pâques les dacor ac ça c'est
peut-être 14 ans qui a patienté
vraiment on se retrouve et puis 2 c'est
très marrant se retrouver là dedans
c'est rigolo parce que les mecs ont pris
ça comme des sénats vers ce compris plus
la musique d'autres ont plus le texte et
surtout se retrouver qu'une écriture
graphique ouais c'est à dire à
l'intérieur même des bandes dessinées
mais j'aurais refusé au maximum de
mettre dedans mais surtout qu'ils
décrivent l'univers moi papa ou d'être
au milieu d'une bande dessinée on se
rend compte que vos chansons se prête
très bien la bande dessinée en tous les
cas c'est qu'il ya vraiment un univers
qui est très bien décrit dans ses
dessins c'est à dire qui on rentre
complètement dans cette histoire on se
sent des mm font un mois quand j'écris
des chansons je suis souvent sur place
effectivement je les fais en plans
larges et je me disais tiens c'est
marrant quand tu joues comme j'étais
assez fan de bandes dessinées et tout à
coup ils m'ont proposé mais je serais
pas allé voir les éditions du soleil
pour leur demander si jamais j'avais
l'idée nommé dans une bande dessinée
s'est passé c'est bon sens contraire que
ça c'est une idée de monsieur charles et
stone camp mercier et féliciter ils
m'ont rendu hommage à chacun ayant bossé
je trouve en tout cas en attirant
l'attention là-dessus que chacun a mis
un maximum de lui-même un talent et eux
se sont pas des mecs comme nous ils
bossent dans le secret derrière leurs
planches on les voit rarement sur des
plateaux télé et moi j'adore ces
artistes parce que finalement ils créent
tout dire que à partir d'un texte au
sénat ou de leur imaginaire il crée tout
ils ont le maximum de figurants ils ont
la plus belle gonzesse de la terre ils
ont le ciel le plus fou ils ont leur
incroyable et pour juste avec leurs
plumes quoi c'est vachement bien plus
j'adore ça nous voulons rendre l e rang
oui bien sûr j'ai des mois la maison
bien alors vous avez déclaré bernard
lavilliers les mecs les plus aventureux
sont les plus pudiques les mecs de ma
race mais de beaucoup de temps à parler
d'eux mêmes alors c'est quoi les mecs de
votre race ça veut dire quoi ça c'est
quoi ta c'est ça
c'est pas ça dans c'est quoi
une race en voie de disparition serait
d'accord très pudique oui évidemment je
suis un mitage ne veut toujours pas me
soumettre mais c'est pas faux c'est vrai
que vous n'êtes pas rentrer vraiment
dans le
système d'une certaine façon pas
vraiment non non non ça me donne une
liberté d'action c'est à dire je peux
encore choisir d'en sortir de temps en
temps d'écrire leur rentrer dedans de me
concentrer nous remettre en question de
prendre mon temps ne pas être venu non
rentabilité qui a à voir avec
l'industrie si on veut c'est pour faire
plaisir que j'ai tablier comme moi je
suis toujours habillée comme vous alors
c'est moi qui viens comme vous c'est
plutôt ça c'est moi j'ai pas de colle ou
et là se tient prêt pour la corde moi je
vais te mettre une boucle d'oreille la
prochaine fois que tu en penses cette
wild bien alors on va parler de votre
vie
bien alors vous êtes d'une famille
modeste vous dites presse le lumpen
prolétariat votre père était
syndicaliste communiste est alors votre
père il avait sauté sur une mine pendant
l'avent la résistance et dans le vercors
été très courageux ils avaient les yeux
brûlés par une mine barcella bloc mans
voilà et il avait deux dixièmes à chaque
oeil et à l'époque et beaucoup de gens
que j'ai rempli des fouilles avant la
guerre bon et le père de bernard quand
il est retourné après dans la halle dans
la vie civile après après le maquis bas
lui retournés en usine il est allé
bosser à la manufacture des armes de
saint-etienne avec deux dixièmes à
chaque oeil sur ses doigts les gens qui
s'était gavé toujours là toute façon et
le kef et toute la guerre héhéhé dans la
1re armée est d'abord le maquis qui
était quand même ils étaient condamnés
comme des droits communs et ils se sont
retrouvés au même endroit avec les gens
qui s'était gavé un quelques autres qui
sont faits canet mais la plupart sont
toujours là sont toujours l'art est donc
effective et à briec delà de votre père
will thermique delattre c'est un bon
exemple et même son garde du corps il
n'a pas eu de prime il a pas eu de
médaille il a pas eu de pension non on
lui a proposé il refuse la refuser votre
mère était institutrice avait quatre
enfants la maison donc c'est vrai que ça
devait pas être facile tous les jours
non pas du tout voilà est alors votre
père ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
bon chemin n'ouvriers il était très
cultivé c'est à dire que par exemple
chez vous vous aviez à l'opéra à
saint-etienne vous alliez vous et là que
pour les l'opéra c'est à dire qu'elle
est quand même cette volonté de de ce
culte iv quoi ils passaient pas son
temps à regarder la télé je pense que
tous les deux avaient ma mère était une
femme très cultivée aussi il faut pas
oublier que mon père il et vivienne 36
ouais la grande question est que leur
principal but c'était de se cultiver
jusqu'à moi ouais c'était pas d'acquérir
des biens matériels c'était la guerre
autre chose alors votre père c'est
plutôt la musique afro cubaine et votre
maire léo ferré donc finalement pas tant
le jazz surtout mon père et puis django
reinhardt et puis tout ce à quoi je veux
dire c'est toute une et puis et puis les
premières chansons de prévert
ça collait bien ou ne faut pas oublier
que par exemple les feuilles mortes
quand il chantait ensemble puisque il
chantait ça ensemble j'ai vu avec moi
une période mais n'est pas enchanté ce
qui est quand même je fais pas si ça
arrivait avec un méchante et les
feuilles mortes s'ils voulaient juste
après guerre les feuilles mortes quand
vous prenez le texte à jour est temps
que tu te souviennes des jours heureux
où nous étions amis en ce temps là la
vie était plus belle le soleil plus
brûlants qu'aujourd'hui si vous mettez
ça juste en fin de la guerre ce poème
qu'un peu sentimental n'y allèrent
simpliste il prend tout à fait une autre
couleur et moi je dis ça avec maman là
dans un vieil appartement ça c'est quand
même différent j'ai quoi pour mener
campagne et une tortue à canary oui bien
sûr non plus mais j'en connais une autre
aussi pour corbillard je vais entrer
doré carrosse conduit par vale bateaux
les plus coquets et j'étais un lundi au
soleil c'est un truc qu'on n'aura jamais
franchement qu'il allait faire sa pièce
de théâtre j'ai des remords bonjour naze
au gymnase le 31 janvier avec bernard
farcy
atteint bonheur
allez j'y allais les joyeux plein pas
aller la voir sa pièce bien alors comme
gtx etiassé malingre
non mais c'est vrai mais celle des
poumons et vos parents n'est pas assez
de pognon pour vous envoyer en
sanatorium et vous envoyer la campagne
votre mère vous donne ne vous donnent
des cours celle qui vous donnent des
cours parce que vous étiez malade etc
n'est qu'à 12 en cause et de viry que
vous venez habiter à saint-etienne dans
un hlm complètement à l'extérieur un oui
quand même
site et ont rappelé à une cité appelant
ses à une cité c'est plus moderne une
barre quoi hélas hélas votre oncle le
frère de votre maire
alain parce que
et voilà
c'est un type qui était un peu voyou
faut 10 rebonds mais qui vous a donné le
goût de la liberté du voyage de l'
aventure relativiser c'est à dire voler
la doc / toujours la tête dans le guidon
qui rate lui il avait une sorte de
distance avec les événements si vous
voulez c'est lui qui m'a appris cette
fameuse phrase dans la vie mon garçon tu
as le choix soit tu travailles soit tu
gagnes de l'argent
résultat soit une jeune avec les aigles
soit upi corps avec les poules est
claire oui mais tu sais pourquoi je dis
ça parce qu'un mec qui me dit mais j'ai
c'est de la merde ce truc c'est dans un
bar et un journaliste je veux pas citer
son nom un comme des wimille et tête des
ventes je le dis il vaut mieux je n'ai
avec les aigles de picorer avec les
poulets ou alors c'est parti de là je
vais tous les proverbes c'est venu
chasser c'est devenu comme les mouettes
pour contrer à quoi c'est un truc et
ouais mais cantona c'est pareil il en
othe géniaux alors résultat des courses
cet oncle donc vous donne le goût de la
relativisation voyages de l'aventuré sur
l'article c'était effectivement de la
distance et non pas de la fuite ou
simplement de la distance on avait juste
et a quand même berlin vous vous
retrouvez en maison de redressement mais
j'assume le ans chez bernard c'est un
goût un taux était tu prépares le guide
du taulard on peut le dire
non mais qui va de pays en pays qui
prend de 3 jours par semaine
oui fourchette dans les tôles de forget
a tranché elle allait bien faire genre
de mission étaient autour les
sud-américains donc à l'époque jeu comme
je les dis vous étiez un peu chétif un
peu un peu malin grawey vous fait de la
boxe pour vous développer ça a marché
oui ça marche mais je dire il ya aussi
une affaire d'agression lascivité
personnel je crois que ma mère m'a mis
au monde en colère maintenant mais c'est
toujours pareil les plus en colère sont
les plus malins général un mec vie sont
sympas les gros ferrat que c'est pour
vraiment inquiéter parce que toute façon
ça serait donc les met en colère qui
sont compliquées dans leur tête qui qui
n'aiment pas être heureux qui se dit
c'est pas pour moi forcément il ya bien
un moment donné où ils apprennent à se
battre je veux dire vous êtes du genre
et du body building quand même après
ouais ouais j'étais même avec une femme
extraordinaire à l'époque c'est vrai les
à la wii qui était championne du
championnat 1re la première championne
du monde de bodybuilding en même temps
la veille la grecque de psycho l'été
pote avec moi c'est grâce à elle que
j'ai connu andré miller quand même juste
à andy murray et l'été pote avec un
email quand même allé le voir s
japonaise il m'a donné un somnifère et
un bouquet extra ordinaire a beaucoup de
fois où j'ai des questions à poser mais
là il y avait des mois il m'intéresse
des livres qui m'intéresse vraiment moi
j'étais marié n'en suis pas très rond
avec la championne du monde de
bodybuilding
est-ce que physiquement excusez moi
c'est un peu un discret comme question
est ce qu'elle est excité physiquement
parce que c'est une montagne de muscles
c'est une ans était pas elle c'est pas
du tout ça c'est ce qui veut dire ils
n'osent pas le dire parce qu'au fond il
est timide est-ce que c'est pas un truc
de [ __ ] de se taper une tuerie
non c'est plus
la question non la question franchement
la vraie question c'est qu'est ce qu'une
femme montagne de muscles à stéphanie
déjà c'était pas est ce qu'une femme
muscler cette semaine voilà répond moi
le da n'a pas ce que je vais pas très
évidente elle m'a apporté beaucoup de
chômeurs et je peux pas en dire du mal
non mais c'est pas le groupe autant
garder un animal exotique mais le voila
voila j'ai dit ma loge d'ordinateurs
dans une salle de boxe je la connaissais
les formidables mais excitante oui il
faut être un peu moi mais je t'aime les
non c'est pas du tout le monstre une
amende c'est pas vrai yama pas
évidemment que c'est ambigu histoire
mais joue à fond pourquoi elle me disait
voilà je suis juive de los angeles qui
fait un sport de noirs [ __ ]
tout est dit ou encore une femme tous
les fans commencent
[Applaudissements]
en continu alors saison vous entrez en
usine ouais laminoir tourneur sur métaux
mais ouvriers p 3 oui et c'est là vous
éclairer vos premières chansons oui
disons que c'est là que j'écris par
exemple les barbares qui sont sur cet
album de bande dessinée belge rama a
extrêmement bien foutu j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'il a fait avec au niveau des seins
franchement
c'est tout à fait les couleurs de sa 1/2
à garder la mémoire de sa gelée toujours
je sais d'où je viens et je sais ce que
j'ai envie seconde jamais renier votre
casse sociale est alors celle là c'est
en fait si l usine ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est l usine vous bossez la
nuit vous prenez le goût de la nuit
cette façon de vivre à l'envers décalé
ouais c'est reste plus le temps le jour
bruce et du sinn qui vous a rendu
marginal d'une certaine façon c'était
déjà pas marrer oui c'est vrai on peut
dire ça mais je veux dire le fait d'être
à cet âge là on n'a pas besoin de moi je
dors pas beaucoup et finalement s'il me
faisais du post 10 heures du soir à 6h
du matin bon ben hamidi j'étais déjà là
ouais donc si vous voulez pas la
pression je travaillais mais je n'avais
pas l'impression d'être attaché au
radiateur la seule chose qui vous
manquait là c'était l'aventuré vous
partez au brésil vous conduisez des
camions de bois précieux en amazonie
alors quand on vous dit bon vous avez
beaucoup raconté de chaussures cette
époque est ce que tout est vrai vous
avez une phrase de sambre arquette ac
oui c'est la fameuse phrase qui dit ce
qu'il disait réserve parce qu'un jeune a
dirigé france soir les connais quand
même bien son art qui lui dit mais ce
que tapas arrosées moi je laissais de
pas pris mais en tous les cas je les
fais prendre à bord et les gens et nous
c'est pareil les camions en amazonie
vous avez dû en prendre alors vous
restez un an et demi au brésil et quand
vous revenez ben l'armée vient de femmes
et là vraiment c'est bien fauqué
pas du tout quand ils vont bien c'est
toujours un homme la preuve c'est que
l'armée bouche à 1 et vous [ __ ] air
l'aller
ils essayent ils essayent ils n'y
arrivent pas ils le foot combien de
temps au mitard 1 en un an mais cac40 à
des associations il était parti sur la
soumission insoumission un an de meta
vous ai fait une chanson là dessus
qu'ils s'appellent qhs ouais c'est une
de vos meilleures chansons et qui
raconte cette expérience donc dans la
forteresse de m alors en 67 vous arrivez
à paris après toutes ces aventures vous
chantez dans les cabarets et là vous
rencontrez rencontré aragon
oui mais lord la aragon et les à triolet
c'était dans un bistrot sa restaurant
qui était tenu par l'irlandais
homosexuels ancien boxeur communiste
effectivement un
aragon est la venelle à neruda et pablo
neruda qui était ami avec aragon est
alors en mai 68 vous êtes un peu de la
vie de pasolini qui disait les vrais
prolétaires c'est les crs
j'avoue préférer aller chanter dans les
usines occupées ouais parce que disait
oui mais c'est un agitateur politique il
complètement anarchiste plus que
chantait ça convenait pas du tout à la
situation comme d'hab d'ailleurs
finalement que ce cochon en général ça
convient pas à la situation en tout cas
pas tout de suite c'est toujours décalé
alors en 71 ses vrais débuts dans la
chanson il faudrait attendre 76 pour
vous fassiez une grande 5
t à brazzaville après barbares quoi dans
le showbiz est resté assez marginal
finalement vos copains sait pas trop ce
du show biz vous dites les gens du
showbiz et moi c'est un peu comme l'eau
et le feu mais jouer des copains
peut-être des réelles une amitié tue pas
sur tout et ami avec quelqu'un peut pas
commencer leurs merdes et 6 6% pas comme
toi tu te fous si on à l'été mais non
non mais n'y a pas de morale dont amitié
thème un mec tu es amis avec lui c'est
tout profit d'al site emmène au bout et
y va ou alors t'es dit parle pas
d'amitié dans ce cas ci commencent à
juger ton ami mais ce que je veux dire
par exemple bernard c'est que vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas dans la bande
des [ __ ] des restos du coeur par
exemple vous êtes un rôle éthiquement
correct moi commençons csu alors vous
dites moi d'abord j'aurais jamais
bouffer au reste et du coeur j'ai quand
même une dignité je veux pas des miettes
du capitalisme c'est plus simple d'aller
braquer une banque quand on n'a pas de
thunes pour bouffer
safex
pour le vent un traversier novak a joués
c'était un côté dames patronnesses ont
mis à la sauce justement des caméras
l'état n'a pas réglé le problème dans
faut bien que les restos oui mais attend
- la charité c'est quelque chose de
tellement liés ça s'appelle comme ça
avec lui au christianisme ça me remet
aux poils sans toi déjà je me gratte et
vous trouvez çà dames patronnesses c'est
à dire ça fait signer au psg de leur
ticket oui vous avez vous pensé par
exemple que c'est un peu comme les gens
les bourgeoises dans le temps qu à les
donner aux pauvres que ça bosse
attention les restos du coeur finalement
vous dites en plus je vois un goût si si
vraiment ça peut être ça peut être est
ce moment là les vrais attention 820
létale mais pour l'instant vous dit que
quand les [ __ ] sont sur scène
finalement ils font un métier qui leur
plaît les gens applaudissent et en plus
qui y passent pour des mecs sympas et
humain donc je ne leur coûte pas grand
chose finalement ça mal hein ouais mais
bon il ya une phrase on fait pas on fait
la charité quand on est des incapables
d'imposer la justice voilà j'ai appris
une chose comme ça c'est vraiment alors
oui c'est vrai c'est clair et net c'est
exact c'est ou bien alors vous savez ce
qu'on va faire maintenant dites moi tout
on va faire une interview croyance
en bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça bouge et du conte à bachy
bien
l'interview croyances et ce en quoi vous
croyez
est ce vous croyez par exemple au père
noël non est ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
dakar est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
manger des fruits de mer même dans les
mois qui sont pas en reste surtout les
moules voilà d'accord
est ce que vous croyez que l'argent ne
fait pas le bonheur
oh oui absolument et d'argent fait pas
le bonheur ah bon ouais je pense pas que
ce soit nécessaire est ce que vous
croyez à l'efficacité des crèmes
antirides
une bonne question mais ça c'est que le
service public à sa noblesse aussi un
avec la vigne était pas son agent il
fait pas son âge mais comment vous ferez
soir comment tu fais quand une fille
j'essaye de ne pas rentrer je sollicite
dans le bac à glace tous les horizons de
décalage horaire ça peut est-ce que vous
croyez à l'amour sans sexe ah non pas du
tout
non
le platonique tout l'arrêt non non non
produits non non est ce que vous croyez
que les drogues douces amène
obligatoirement aux drogues dures pas de
tout
ouais
est ce que vous croyez la télépathie
ouais tout à fait à l'homéopathie
bon et aguiche patty est ce que vous
croyez j'espère que oui oui complètement
j'aime beaucoup moins vous y croyez vous
bien sûr je donne beaucoup aussi au
voyage pâté
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu